فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
آيس كريم آيس كريم  نكهته شهية وتدوم    من لا يأكله محروم
صوتك خشن انت الثعلب اذهب اذهب يا كذاب مادامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراب
فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق دق دق
من بالباب
أنا مهرج هووبا هووبا        هيا تعالوا ودعوا الكلب   من يخرج ويريد اللعب
صوتك خشن انت الثعلب اذهب اذهب يا كذاب مادامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراب
لا لا
فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق  دق دق
من بالباب
أهلا أرسلني والدكم   بالسيارة كي آخذكم     هيا اخرجوا كي أوصلكم
صوتك خشن انت الثعلب اذهب اذهب يا كذاب مادامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراب
فى منزل أنثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
دق  دق دق
من بالباب
أنا بابا ها قد عدت       بعد دوام لكم اشتقت   بالأكل والحلوى جئت
أهلا أهلا   يا ثعلوب      أفسدت عليك الملعوب
هههههههه
هذا الوالد آه يا ويلي          فلأهرب كي أنجو بذيلي
هاهاها....... يا كذاب انت الثعلب هيا اذهب لا لا لن نفتح هذا الباب